kowalski frigo taper dans une moi vous
avez vu ce truc là cet art neuf tu sais
tous les ans on perd quelques heures
c'est la nature pas je vais vous dire je
rejette la nature qui est avec moi
minuscules et sans défense les bébés un
mois sont pétrifiés de terreur ils
savent que ces tombes de cette falaise
c'est la mort qui les attend vas-y
jean-claude nerveux regardez le miracle
de la lune un moment d'une
extraordinaire beauté
bonjour c'est pour ma famille qui n'a
pas de famille et on va tous mourir
qu'il prend cette année
découvrez comment quatre frères sont
devenus les pingouins de madagascar
je te tiens tu vas parler c'est un des
meilleurs délais qui nous commandons
qu'on attrape ses noix de coco et on les
sert bien va s'emballer ce qui nous
approchons de notre objectif
rico il travaille dans une toute autre
dimension soldats
il faut faire diversion vous habitez
chez voir et pour la première fois
et quoi que tu es confidentielle mon nom
n'est pas confiné m'ennuie
confidentielles et va il n'y a qu'une
solution pour se mettre d'accord
s'embrasser travail d'équipé c'est
exactement ce que j'avais proposée est
dynamique il était chargé de le remettre
les maillots ils ont pas marre ils ont
quitté la joie et moi je me la joue
aussi alors on nage en plein délire
en fait
je vous salue l'effort bino vous avez
fait la reconnaissance de mes anciennes
en l'instant comment sa relation ya
jamais eu de relation entre les
pingouins de madagascar de dreamworks
nous emporterons ça dans notre ont
beaucoup aidé